okay guys it's your boy psychobabble and
we're playing this game called
perfection I know I know it looks
beautiful but is that a good game well
sitting that's just played us huh yes
yes absolutely yes I need that to make
your wildest dreams turn into a reality
oh my god that's the best thing I've
ever heard
yes yes yes yes let's see this I'm so
excited
[Music]
let's do this hey kid about a perfection
in progress I'd like to put that to
complete you know what I mean okay
ah okay yeah nice has it it's [ __ ]
late in the air that [ __ ]
I signed an or something or what that to
lunch I can't be waiting okay
I guess we'll do this in the meantime
perfection in progress it looks like
it's loading [ __ ]
and okay that wreck I love it enter your
name to login mister Babel okay
ma'am I think what you want drink you
feel almost easy I like this one I guess
I don't like that one he actually lonely
can't move inspect thank you oh good
it's me that's gonna [ __ ] I get ready
and prepare for a perfection that's
[Music]
please describe your symptoms
perfections perfect would like perfect
me you would have shirt black hair
instead of my shaved head that be
slimmer but still stocky they're
confident okay what is this horizon No
never better
can't perfection to be manufactured
absolutely everybody knows that
please enter mister Babel okay hold on
let me see that painting
yeah that's outside well that's a
[ __ ] nice ass holy [ __ ] why would I
go anywhere else not in use hello ma'am
yeah bad I felt that I yeah a beautiful
lips that I beautiful oh don't let
anyone tell you otherwise
okay I'm not it guys talking it a sec
get away from me can you hear that
sounds like perfection who's talking
imperfections your ship to perfect its
happiness like result it
wait there's a wave like look in it you
can't look at it okay it's the lady
never better okay I guess I gotta be
perfect let's say here yeah hello sir
that is that warning cannot be
dissembled without product failure
perfection heads okay
holy [ __ ]
I play some weird [ __ ] yeah yes oh oh oh
my god my tits yeah there's like force
you way to look at my breasts okay
second grain out how am I going
how about sorry and I can't even yeah is
it like a birth control what is that
let's see a birth control strip oh yeah
why that that's a yes I'm here this is
think about that says do not disturb but
I keep looking in here
it's definitely someone in there let me
[ __ ] see you it is you for
okay that's blood back down here hello
Lincoln la I gettin scared here
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] Thanks I'm getting
sick it is it is not that hard to get a
sec alright I was out in the waiting
room
I was ok guys are gonna thank you again
ma'am I'm trying to get in here how is
that oh I see there's a person in there
take a doctor or something well I tried
to help you sir I tried to help you Dana
yes
can I look in here what's in here
there's some dirt on the wall
the waiting round anyone out there
do I need this not the [ __ ] used I
think that over thing literally
everything unsecured yeah my perfection
is necessary and you absolutely need it
what is that genican touch that
hello sir
how late I laid out I'm so ugly he's got
like a what is that oh he's got like a
wire he's checking me can I get out of
here I guess I just take this this
hasn't happened I'm pressing resume
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] break [ __ ]
clinched ya little [ __ ]
oh I like walking how do I stop him oh
it's [ __ ] weird I appreciate the
right sugar okay never mind it did not
freeze play that that mistake my father
hey thanks it are they gonna get really
mad safley let me get in here it's gonna
fight me I know it is
the staff entrance
it's a [ __ ] over there self in ignore
her
come on [ __ ]
what's it been oh yeah see I guess I got
a fight this match right oh [ __ ] he's
sucking hideous patient man mr. Babel in
imperfection of target fear being alone
George dopamine external his patient
curious about environment curious mix
hyper where the surroundings there's a
patient file orders yes they obey taking
her as your actual this day they should
promising signs at the page
system error of rejection patient means
imperfect we remain imperfect you're
whoa it's just [ __ ] Exeter me I guess
that's it that's what you're saying
I don't know what that was I really like
how it you have to choose the beginning
and kind of builds up to what you want
Wow okay all right now you're gonna play
this to ETL as a link in the description
fun yeah thank you